[Music]
in ring shaming news ring Sammy hey what
is that ring JV like [ __ ] or rock is
too little she's like nah ah this is
perfect she's like for someone that's
poor or when they call it cute when they
call you're being cute is that info and
this was submitted by jay-z's laughs
woman a diamond ring at her boyfriend's
things and proceeded to make an
ungrateful Facebook post the dude
surprised to talk [ __ ] about the ring
man [ __ ] rings dude I think rings are
the [ __ ] dumbest [ __ ] of course imma
get her a ring but it's not gonna be
crazy though because it's just like for
me crazy its relative with craziness
you're like 10 G's that's like that's a
lot of money for a for a ring that's as
much as I'm gonna say well what's
nothing is nothing
it's nothing for her average in like
America is like 2/3 okay I'm doing work
it was like 6,000 and this was like a
high-end store so like most people okay
I'm going 6,000 thank you so none of us
are in like the 9 to 5 life right I
found out from the 9 of 5 perspective
because we talk about this stuff all the
time
talk about rings a lot I mean marriage
engagement like the 9 to 5 lifestyle
buying a house buying a car like that
kind of stuff like the typical steps
that people have with the stepping
stones I found out just recently that
you're supposed to spend 3 months
paycheck that's the dumbest whatever it
is so if you make 5 grand a month it
should be 15,000 if you make 10 grand a
month there should be 30,000 if you make
one like 3 months a check yes and
diamonds we always say pre-tax guys
pre-tax so we can get more Commission
like before you take tax out of your
paycheck so it's three months pre-tax oh
that's a lot of money
yeah wait so then on average people
should be paying like twelve thousand if
you do the three months they'll [ __ ]
that's a lot of money yeah I got much
across the country Yeah right I mean if
you like rings that's cool but for me
like because my parents don't wear their
rings and they never have and they've
had a very successful marriage I can't
like morally it bothers me well cuz
they're Korean tradition we're talking
about American tradition now okay gives
a [ __ ] about where's your mom's your mom
your mom's generation though it was the
same cuz that's the older generations it
depends because my mom's generation when
she was growing up in Mexico no but then
when she came to the America yes so it
or the ring is the ring thing an
American thing I think so because I know
the marketing behind it it was all
invented by the diamond industry but I
didn't know how long it went and how
much it hollered spread out yeah how far
it's spread out can you educate us we
like De Beers is like the biggest mining
company for diamonds and they mine a
[ __ ] ton of diamonds but they only
release a certain amount every single
year so that they can limit the supply I
heard that if they come to America then
they go to jail how they violate the
monopoly laws oh yeah I don't know I
have no idea I just meant they the
biggest miners yeah but I will say this
from a girl perspective okay
tell me if you guys feel this way what I
feel like I get treated differently when
I went where my ring out you're not the
first person to say but yes how
different like I just get better service
like that's the only reason I care about
like bags sometimes because it's like I
get better service oh they feel like
you're from a different class of people
yeah so they like treat you better
I'll see that's different though I hang
out with some gutter ass people so it
doesn't matter these are the human
beings imperfect about his wedding ring
I go ever since we got married and he's
been wearing a ring he's like yeah they
treat me like if I'm older yeah
gets more respect they treat me like
[ __ ] still are you talking about from
sales people everywhere so they still
treat me like [ __ ] cuz we have a tenant
adviser like someone that helps us lease
and get office spaces and so we're
working on this deal with our building
and one of our tenant advisors associate
who I met before was walking with a
group of other people in suits to come
look at our building so it was like one
white guy in a suit with five other
white guys in a suit they're probably
gonna look for one of the owners of the
entire business complex which is either
me or Jill but because I'm always
wearing my target shorts and sandals I
walked right past them and I was like
hey guys and I knew they were looking
for me yeah and they just looked at me
and they didn't even acknowledge me they
walked right past me and then I walked
into my apparel meeting and I was like
they're looking for me but they don't
even know that I was the owner of this
[ __ ] but if I'm sure you're
wearing your ring yeah but you were also
wearing said you know you were you
waiting your watch cuz usually guys it's
the y-yeah but I think my target shorts
overrode the [ __ ] watch yeah really
for girls it's bags damn I don't give a
sh I know those people though if you if
let's see if you ever got on like a nice
car dealership or Road day or whatever
the minute you walk in you already seem
to go they already got your whole
profile oh [ __ ] probably makes a hundred
grand a year whatever has day's worth
that's true cuz I'll Drive up with my
Honda Civic in like berlioz I feel so
low class oh my god well that's the best
part though dude like if I go to a
richer area I specifically Drive a Honda
Element me too yeah I Drive the [ __ ] car
instead of Italian gold out even white
the eye boogers off my house I wish she
was lying but he's telling alright so
this story here this girl she posted
this in this Facebook group called ring
shaming this group has messed up yeah
there's a whole group yes Facebook group
called ring shaming where like I'll just
go and talk [ __ ] about rings and then
Oh self shame Friday here I come found
this in the boyfriend's nightstand not a
fan
please roast and then tell me how to
tactfully say no you need to go get
something different and this is he
worked his ass off hard I think you need
to go get something different I apply
that to the man I don't know [ __ ] about
race but to me looks good yeah no you're
right it's stupid to me yeah it's just
the [ __ ] ring man like and my thing
too is like I like jewelry a lot of
people disagree with me too but like you
know like I don't even like it when the
girl tells me what to get her because
for me a ring is like this is my token
of appreciation to you if you don't
[ __ ] like it then don't [ __ ] marry
me that's it and it is because like
let's say you lose it right are we going
to are we gonna get divorced let's say
it disappears it goes away what does it
actually mean if it's a Korean girl you
get divorced the marketing behind it is
prove your love to someone by the size
of the ring right like it's kind of like
a dowry like you can prove that you can
provide it's like a modern day I asked
her I was like I was like Jill would you
rather want me to down pay a house for
us or would you rather me buy your ring
at your the house I don't want to
[ __ ] ring I don't want you to burn
money like I like jewelry you know right
this is great you know what I mean I
just think that when somebody looks at
it as like this is the value that you
have for me in our relationship is where
I have a problem because that's where I
have an issue with - it's like you can't
value what I given you over the past
like ten years of us being together
through this [ __ ] object because
whether you lost that object or not
we're still gonna stay together and I
still love you so what the [ __ ] was
because you know you're not brainwashed
that's why the marketing didn't work on
you yeah maybe my parents just hella
ghetto to that I see my mom just
I don't think it's brainwashing I also
think that a lot of people just value
tradition and if that's an American
tradition that they grew up with and
that's kind of what they value and it's
like very new tradition yeah I mean but
it's the tradition regardless it's it's
let there's a mochi shop in downtown LA
that's older than this tradition that's
like less than a hundred years yeah I
don't mind it like I'm wearing a ring
[Laughter]
but what you're said what you're saying
is I'm not against either because you
like the symbolism now what people what
I mean is like people who drink the
kool-aid so far beyond oh they don't
even understand what's going on they
just want it for the really think that
the value of the ring proves the love
yes small leap they're like oh he
doesn't love me that much right there
that exists and I'm that's what I don't
want right here because you're still
gonna get a ring I'm not against rings
in general yeah I think it's like that's
that's really true because before as you
guys know I used to be engaged before
Casey and with that guy I really did not
like deep down inside I kind of like I
try to fake myself and try to convince
myself yeah I did want to be with this
guy and like okay let's make it work but
then when he proposed to me and he
showed me the ring and I was just like
that's exactly what I thought it wasn't
let me down much he doesn't love me that
much but then now looking back you're
not respected I'm just like I was just
not feeling that relationship at all and
I just blamed it on the ring and I was
just using the ring as an excuse not
wanna go - see that's that's the best
what I'm talking about there's like a
truth in there that's true cuz if the
relay if the relationship is bomb as
[ __ ] and you're on a high he could get
you like real so they made out of twigs
and you'd be like oh my god that's the
symbol
after that whole experience with that
guy and then now like now with Casey I
think is a lot smaller and you were like
I love you no hell no like Casey went
above and beyond I even told him not to
give me a real diamond so anyway like I
was just like you know if you could have
given me like a piece of [ __ ] thing but
because I feel like that relationship is
true and I really wanted to be with him
like I really wouldn't have gone to [ __ ]
if he gave me the Rima what if he was
like will you marry me but not the best
ring idea - this is extremely personal
and very private pubic yes it's a
braided pubic hair and they see this
curly as much are there gonna be some
part of his body you actually said that
before that's why yeah but still the
diamond on it is just dangling I have a
bad one how about this you come nope huh
I get circumcised genius
the foreskin on top of your [ __ ] feet
drive it shrinks it expands [ __ ]
but it's soft it's that
[Music]